let's ask you the last question what is
the last question uh you were named
salons Sexiest Man of the Year of 2013 I
don't know what does that mean
I don't I really don't know I thought it
was its first of all let's say it fueled
by white guilt and that's that is a
hundred percent true so long I tell
myself yeah but it would have been big
comedians are supposed to be you know
soft and you're soft oh oh god I just
benched 450 that would be like how much
Superman benches is that a lot 450
pounds you don't have to answer it but
just think in your head how much do you
weigh
I weigh about two thirty thirty so it
would be benching two of you that's a
lot of view you'd have to look like
Superman to do who do you bench me yeah
you could turn a stick
like I'll like make you like into a
football person then I could do it this
is gonna end poor this I think you would
have to time of my life mate oh that
would be brave
you couldn't clear the song go are you
gonna do it they just want to see blood
Hey
how are we gonna do it well you'd have
to lie down there's no way this is gonna
happen all right I'll get on the floor
how is this gonna work
let go also want people to know you
could review the tape later that my
hands didn't come down he didn't get the
balance right so I know I did that him
up how I did it yeah it was luck yeah I
could have held you there my whole life